So here's how we could define factorial. And,
we should go back to our mathematical definition. That's
what we want to turn into code. We had our
base case where factorial is 0. The result should
be 1. And we had our recursive case, where
there is input is greater than 0. We want to
have the result be n times factorial of n
minus 1. So we can turn that fairly straightforwardly
into code, so here's the code. We're going to define
a procedure. Just like the previous definition, we have
one input, it's a number. We'll call it n. Now we need to have the code, so we
need to first check if we've reached the base
case, so we'll use an if for that. And
we're going to check if if n is equal to
0, remember we need the double equals for the comparison.
That means we've reached the base case. And we
defined that value factorial as 0, is defined as
1. So that means when n equals 0, what
we should do is return the value of 1. When
it is not equal to 0, we'll use else for the case where n is not equal to 0.
Well then we have the recursive case. And that
was given by the definition, that the factorial of n,
for numbers greater than 0, is equal to n times factorial of n minus 1. So
that's exactly what we want to do in the
Python kid. We'll turn the new result, which
is n times the result we get, calling factorial passing in n minus 1. And this
may seem strange that we're defining factorial using
factorial. It seems like that's kind of circular,
but the reason that it's not circular, is because we
have this base case. That we have a case, where we
do stop, we stop once we reach the case where
n is equal to 0, and because every time we call
factorial, instead of passing in the same value of n
that we started with, we're passing in n minus 1. It's
getting smaller. Eventually we're going to get to 0, assuming that we
started with n as some positive whole number. So we eventually
stop, return one. And on the way there,
we're going to be multiplying in all these values.
So let's step through what happens when we
run this code. So let's look at an example.
Suppose we called factorial passing and three. So
that means we're going to enter the procedure here.
The value that n refers to is going to
be 3 inside the body of factorial. We're going to
try the comparison. It is not equal to 0, so
we don't return 1. So we're going to go to the else.
And that means we're going to return the value of n
times factorial of n minus 1. So that means we're computing
the value of n times factorial then and n minus
1, well, n was 3, so n minus 1 is 2.
That's what happened as a result in the first call.
But we're not done, right. We still need to evaluate this,
so now we're evaluating factorial of 2. That means we're
entering factorial again. This time the value of n will
refer to 2. We do the comparison, n is not
equal to 0 so we go to the else clause.
Now, we're going to return the result of n times factorial
n minus 1. In this case, the value of n
is 2. So the value of factorial of 2 will
be 2 times the result we get by calling factorial,
passing in the value of n minus 1, so calling
factorial passing in 1. And remember that was part of
the return, where we had 3 times factorial 2. So
we still have the 3 times. But now we're getting
the result of factorial 2. It's 2 times something. We're
calling factorial again. We still don't know what factorial of
1 is. So that means we're going to reenter factorial. We
finished here. We're doing the call. We're going to re-enter factorial,
but this time the value of n now refers to 1. And now again
this test is false. So we go to the else clause. And now we're going to return n
which is 1 times the result of factorial 0. So now, we're calling factorial 0.
We're going back into the procedure. Now, the value of n refers to is 0. And,
now, this test is actually true, n equals 0.
So, we'll go to the return here. We return 1,
that means the result of factorial 0 is 1,
so to get the result of factorial 1, we had
1 times factorial 0, that's 1 times 1, which
is 1, and now to get the result back from
factorial 2, we had 2 times factorial 1, which we
now know is 1. So we're going to have, the result
here as 2. And to get the result for factorial
3, we have 3 times factorial 2, which we know
has the value 2, will get the result, as 6.
And note the way we've defined it, well if we tried
instead, factorial 4, if we started with factorial 4, what
would have happened is the first time we go through, we
get 4 times factorial 3. So factorial 4 would be
4 times factorial 3. Well we had factorial 3 as 6,
4 times 6 would give us 24, which is the result of factorial 4.